okay
all right here we go let's do it
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back
[Music]
we got some great art
this is before i hate my boyfriend's
couch
what's my dude's name
he's on instagram i'll tell you about it
later
rg v underscore arts i want to thank him
for that artwork for this week's
background episode i want to talk about
kyrie irving not playing a little bit of
vaccine stuff i want to talk about um
follow-up of last week because that was
pretty interesting conversation
and i'm doing a big spoiler alert review
of titan
[Music]
all right whatever
thanks for being here live guys i had to
do it live once again i'm always i go
live when my weekend is a mess okay
that's what that's what i do i go live
when my weekend is a mess right but
listen
before we even start uh let here we go
uh shout out to
doordash
okay doordash sponsor of the show what
do you want to eat tonight maybe you
want uh you know your favorite home
cooked
favorites brought right to your house
get 25 off and zero delivery fees on
your first order of 15 or more when you
download the door dash app
all right
and enter code griffin you hear me get
25 off enter code griffin shout out to
doordash sponsor of the show
okay
let's do it um all right so first up
i got this great art that was sent to me
actually today
uh
rg rjv arts uh let's go to his uh
there we go that's his instagram right
there uh
yeah interesting artist he's got some
good work there he sent me this and so
i'm giving him a shout out or her i
don't know
him or her whatever
you know
but this is like
i showed this to rachel she laughed so
this is like are we still trying to do
our little i hate my boyfriend's couch
on um
you know so just come check that out
when we it's just
the holidays are just weird man
holly's weird and we're doing this live
so shout out to everybody watching live
on youtube
how you doing
you know what i mean it's good to see
you guys out here um
you know
uh
thanks for you know being here you know
sometimes you know i don't give no
notification nothing but you guys get
the notifications so make sure you you
know hit the notifications button right
there if you want to see it live like
this and so you so you don't miss out on
it and you know i'm always on twitch too
i do twitch daily eric griffin gaming so
make sure you check me out on air
me and that
well mostly every day but eric griffin
gave me on twitch all right and i also
put those videos up on eric griffin
gaming on youtube my other youtube
channel so check those out too man
so uh thanksgiving
excuse me thanksgiving passed um
it was a rough thanksgiving for me
because i was not feeling well uh i had
like a sinus infection and then i was
concerned i was like oh my god do i have
covid so i had like some home cover
tests so i took like three of them three
days in a row just to make sure and i
was good it really was just a sinus
infection which is good
because you never know like these days
you know you're not feeling well that's
the first thing you think of you like
you know you got whatever's going on you
feel like you sniffles whatever it's
like oh no i have kovitz that sucks it's
such that we live in a world like that
but it is what it is so i had to do that
you know because i still had shows and
stuff and i didn't want to be out here
getting people sick or whatever it is
like that you know so but then it
subsided and i was like all right i went
out it just affected my voice but i
still had a good time but thanksgiving
was cool you know i didn't like we were
gonna go over to rachel's parents house
but we didn't go because
i just wasn't feeling well and i didn't
want to risk
you know anything getting them sick you
know what i mean especially her dad um
you know because he had some stuff going
on and i didn't i wanted to he we should
be healthy around him so we didn't go
there so instead rachel and i went to uh
century city and we went to the um
where did we go del frisco's they had
like a little thanksgiving thing going
on and it was cool
you know it was nice i love spending
time with rachel is great so you know
when we're together it doesn't matter
what we're doing and just it just was
cool we had a cool time the food was
delicious and we just had a good time
together you know and rachel has a bunch
of decorations up now you know rachel's
jewish so she has like her like
yesterday was the first day of hanukkah
i believe i don't know so she you know
so she got the menorah with the candles
lit and then we also got a christmas
tree so she got the christmas tree and
she like got the lights on the christmas
tree
and above the christmas tree it's like
happy hanukkah
i actually should have oh man i'm
slipping i should have taken a picture
of that and showing you guys that maybe
i'll have that be the background for
next week is the picture of the living
room with the happy hanukkah and all
that kind of stuff on there so you know
oh man so um yeah i didn't want to
you know i guess i i it was like a up
and down thanksgiving so it you know it
is what it is you know it's like you
know holidays are great when you have
somebody to share them with you know so
i've just been a perpetual bachelor for
so long that it's different now you got
somebody in your life and you're just
like now you understand what the
holidays are all about you know it's
like sharing that time and it was nice i
was thankful for
uh rachel being here with me and you
know me being with her and the time that
we spent together it was it was good but
i had like a little
little scare too because you know you
guys know i'm talking about my mom my
mom's got dementia and of course my
step-dad calls me and he's like eric
your mom took off
you know because my you know my mom
thinks her grandmother's alive she
thinks her grandmother her long dead
grandmother she thinks is alive and
lives down the street so sometimes she
just gets fed up i guess she's like in
this thing now so she gets her dressed
gets her coat on and all this stuff and
she just starts walking to grandma's
house
of course she's don't know where she is
she's just walking walking walking so
far and then she fell down you know so
we had to call the police and some some
somebody helped her thank goodness
there's good people out there
you know so she had like a black eye and
like you know it's still i'm talking to
her and she just doesn't know i go mom
you know she was like well michael's
with me and i'm like no he wasn't you
know but it's like what can you do
so luckily she's okay so now we really
gotta consider they're in an independent
living place but it might be time for
some more help
so that's um
it's hard you know it's hard so you know
shout out to anybody that's dealing with
like alzheimer's dementia and their
family because it's like it's really all
on you you know like i'm an only child
man when you're only child it's tough
you know i got no support
you know my stepdad you know he's there
by himself too i ain't even doing enough
to help him you know what i mean
so i don't know anyways i don't want to
go into all that
so um last week
um
you know last week we had a real heated
discussion
about uh what happened with or what's
his face
kyle rittenhouse remember this from last
week oh hey he's back uh just want to
say i enjoyed all the discourse in the
comments you know i was in the comments
too i wanted to like you know because
people had a lot of things to say
i just wish
if you if you disagree
or if you have something to say
express yourself you know if you say i
disagree with you tell me why you
disagree with me like if you went out of
your way to write a comment and say i
disagree because i feel this way there
was a lot of rude ignorant ass people in
the comments who like they just want to
attack like they're so like you have a
little brain if your first thing to do
is attack me as opposed to just being
like because like to me
i know the people in the comments
that attacked me they didn't watch the
whole video they didn't watch everything
that i said they only watched what they
wanted to say that got heated and then
they attacked me
you know and that was it
but for all you people that like had a
really intelligent back and forth i
appreciate you
you know i appreciate the like you know
the back and forth and you know i hope
you understand where i was coming from i
want to clear some things up i will say
like i know that some people thought
when i was making the dog comparison
that i was trying to say that those
people could sue him that was not the
point of that the point i was trying to
make is how the laws are different
for um
how the laws can be different for
certain things how you can be held
accountable for your dog doing something
you know based off the fact that it's um
vicious right
uh
but then like i was trying to say that a
weapon is like it's always lethal but
you don't you're not necessarily
accountable for that that was really the
point i was trying to make with that but
actually even as i say that i mean those
people actually could their families
could sue him but it might get thrown
out i mean who knows you know what i
mean like they could
try to get a civil trial that you know
he brought a weapon and and their family
member died you know i i don't know how
those particular laws work i'm not a i'm
not a lawyer i was just saying how the
laws you there's different laws for
different things based off that but i
thought it was a good discussion
um and thank you for the people that got
involved i i enjoyed being in the
comments with you guys and so that was
pretty interesting but again we're not
going to go
all into that i just wanted to give you
you know thanks for that
so something i did want to talk about
today is
good ol oh wait why is this like that oh
man
the the it's all messed up see this is
what happens when you do it when you're
doing [ __ ] live
[Laughter]
you know what i mean oh here we go here
we go boom
get him down there he is
uh okay i fixed it
so anyways oh and thank you for the
super chat i appreciate the super chat
um from uh canada i believe that is so
good i'm using kyrie irving as an
example uh of this subject that i want
to talk about is that you know so kyrie
irving
so there's
a vaccination law in
new york
that
to be indoors or to work if you work in
new york i believe
and you know i don't know for what but
it's something about being in new york
you have to be vaccinated to work in new
york kyrie irving doesn't want to get
vaccinated and so now he can't play
and so you know he's sitting on the
bench even though he's making half his
salary he's making 17 million dollars so
he's not let's not act like he's a hero
okay you know what i mean but it is what
it is so you know it's tough situation
you know i ask myself how do i feel
about this and i think it's different
for everyone i think it's different for
everyone so there is he does fall under
the young and healthy category of like
can someone like that a professional
athlete fight off covid more so than the
rest of society probably i think if
kyrie irving gets covet
most likely he's going to like
it's going to be fine for him he's going
to pass over he's going to pass through
it okay but uh the people that he
interacts with
because why are you taking the vaccine
you know that's the big question i think
you have to ask yourself are you taking
the vaccine for yourself
or are you taking the vaccine for other
people and i think it's different for
depending on where you are at stage in
life i mean i you know i'd like to think
that we're taking the vaccine in the
same way we're wearing masks we wear a
mask not for ourself but for other
people we're taking the vaccine you know
you take it so if you get it but also so
you don't spread it
that's the that's what they're saying
i don't know
i don't get why kyrie irving is not
taking this vaccine i don't get it this
stance that he's taking like he's like
looking out for the little people who
are being forced to take the vaccine
it's weird because i almost understand
that
i almost understand it but i don't
believe in it like i don't think that
that's strong enough
you know we've done like over a billion
people have taken this thing and you
know we don't really know
what the long-term effects are going to
be
we don't even know the long-term effects
of covid actually i don't i don't know
yet i don't know if like this has been
around for a year and a half so we don't
know like in five years the people that
have had covet are they still gonna have
some lung issues or something i don't
know or how about the people that have
taken the vaccine like is there gonna be
some lingering thing like you know is
that what he's waiting for is that what
the anti-vaxxers are waiting for to be
like ah you see everybody's ears fell
off or whatever it is i don't know if
that's gonna be the case now i'm not
again i'm not a scientist i'm not a
doctor guys i'm just trying to talk
common sense of just how i perceive this
thing but to me it just feels like if
you're gonna
if you know not like some people are
allergic to things like when you go to
the doctor even if you go to the dentist
or anything and they're gonna give you
anything they always ask you are you
allergic to any medication i mean people
are allergic to stuff people are gonna
have a adverse reaction two things
that
most people do not have a reaction to uh
what's an example like insulin i mean
there are people who are alert very it's
a small percentage but there are people
who might be allergic to that so that's
not going to be the thing that's going
to help them it might actually hurt them
even latex i mean there are people who
are allergic to latex it doesn't mean
latex is wrong it doesn't mean insulin
is wrong it's just for that person it's
not good so should we all not do it
because
you know a few people and it is a few
people so you know i don't know like all
these studies people are talking about
these like armchair scientists and then
looking online they're googling effects
of the vaccine and they're using that as
a justification to be like well i'm not
gonna take it because look
i don't know man i think there's enough
stories of people
i think there's enough stories of people
that are unvaccinated with health issues
age weight problems that are dying in
the hospital to be like all right
i think i think we should take this but
again it's anadolu to you for me i'm
almost 50 i am not in great shape i got
that vaccine like this
because i saw the numbers about people
that are obese
they're in the hospital they're dying to
covet you know so i was like all right
you know what i'm for me
i took it
i'm glad my parents took it they got
coveted with the vaccine my stepfather
has pre-existing conditions like a
asthma he i think cover would have
killed him probably he was it was
terrible to see him in the hospital so i
was like all right
i was watching first take today and
steven a smith was telling a story about
a family friend of his who was
overweight
a complete anti-vaxxer
died a covet in the hospital
i mean there's a lot of stories like
this
so
for me at my age my health level
i took it i felt like it was important
for me to take it and i wanted my
parents to take it
if you're a young person out there and
you're just like hey i don't want to
take this i respect your right okay
and i also feel like
i get this idea that like it feels like
people are being forced to take it you
know
like just saying hey we're not we're not
telling you to take the vaccine it's
just if you want to live in america you
have to take
you know what i mean and like it feels
like that so i kind of get this like you
know they're it's like you have one side
who's saying we're trying to do this to
help you we're trying to you know we're
looking out for you because you're not
looking out for yourself so you got to
do this thing and so i can i can
understand people being like hey man
this is against my rights this is
america you know i get that and that's
the stance that kyrie irving is trying
to take i think
but i just don't agree with it
i just i just don't you know i i feel
like
i feel like there's not enough there's
not enough evidence
just to just to be like
hey i don't want to take this because
it's going to mess me up
i don't where where are those i think
that those things but who even knows
what this media to in this day and age
would those like stories be front and
center man like are those stories going
to be front and center of being like
here's a hundred thousand people who
have taken the vaccine and
this has happened but even if a hundred
thousand people drop dead from the
vaccine
out of
billions of people that have taken it i
think those are great odds in terms of
like the what we're trying to protect
from but again listen have your own
opinion i'm just saying i think it all
depends on who you are and what stage of
life you're in if you are not young and
healthy
i i have a problem with you talking
about i'm not taking this vaccine
if you're one of these in this group of
people that can easily spread it easily
catch it easily die from it
so you know so you know again it's like
it's so layered what's my favorite word
y'all nuanced
[Laughter]
gotta say nuance on them sigma
so who knows
so i don't i don't i don't get
i don't i just i don't get why
i don't get why like he's doing this
you know and then now what are they
gonna do first of all the nets don't
need them that's what they're proving
even with all the stuff that's going on
and that's got the number one seed in
the east they're playing great right now
they've gotten it together it was weird
at first i think they're figuring
themselves out
the nets have already said we ain't
going to resign this dude because
there's one thing after another with him
it's like he leaves the team for
whatever reason he doesn't show up you
know it was like he didn't go to the
bubble remember when he didn't go to the
bubble he's always getting hurt like
it's like there's so many like baggage
with him that his talent isn't
outweighing all this baggage man
so
i don't know
i don't know
you know
like he's cost himself two championships
um by no by his his by no fault of his
own other than he's injury prone
so the first year when he was with
lebron james in cleveland he gets
injured i think they win the
championship against golden state if
he's healthy just him
just if he's healthy
they took him to six games and it was
just lebron and dellavedova
and then last year
the nets were beating the brakes off the
milwaukee bucks with kyrie irving i mean
20 point wins he goes down milwaukee
wins
so he would have three championships i
think
maybe more
maybe
golden state okay okay check this out
maybe cleveland beats golden state year
one right
they have the confidence now golden
state don't have this confidence that
their champs maybe they don't come back
to next year and win 73 games and
cleveland goes on a run they won the
next year anyway you get what i'm saying
so maybe lebron would have won
back-to-back championships and then they
would have got maybe they would have
then got
uh
kevin durant or maybe because golden
state wasn't in this championship mode
maybe oklahoma city would have beat
golden state that year and then it would
have been oklahoma city cleveland in the
championship you know like the whole
thing would have changed just because of
kyrie irving's injury so anyways
like i say man i think it is a very uh
strange
choice that he's making i respect his
choice i just don't believe his
rationale is correct like he's he's
always talking about he's doing this for
the little people but i don't believe
him i don't know i don't you know when
you got so much money in the bank maybe
he just doesn't even want to play
anymore for some reason but like what's
he waiting on at this point it's pride
you know like what what is he waiting on
that's gonna happen like life is going
on the nba is going on i think people
that are anti-vaxxed they really want
everyone to drop dead like they really
want so they can be like this aha you
see i told you
but other than that
what are you waiting on
you know if you're young and healthy
then if you're young and healthy and you
can overcome covet
then wouldn't you feel like a young
healthy person can overcome side effects
of the vaccine but who knows i'm not a
scientist you know it maybe it's not a
correlation to that
uh you know maybe it's not the same you
know they affect things differently
if you if you are a doctor or scientist
and you know one i do have one question
for anybody out there that is like
really like knows this answer
but if you do have
an adverse reaction to the vaccine
does that also mean that covid
affects you more than affects other
people
is that
does that happen
you guys know what i'm saying that is a
question that i would really love a
doctor or a scientist someone to answer
for me
um
you know let me say it again
if you have a reaction to the vaccine
would you then also
have a reaction
to
[Music]
the covet in the same way like are you
more susceptible to that because if
that's the case then you gotta throw
those numbers out like who cares you
know
that is a question that i would love a
doctor because a doctor might say like
oh no it's not the same thing or or they
might be like yes you know i don't know
um
[Music]
let's see uh oh somebody you know
somebody just asked a very a very
interesting question um
let's see uh let me go back to let me go
back to my
regular background so that's the kyrie
irving oh before i even look at that
question uh you know what let's go to
let's get back into our sponsor
um you know guys doordash
doordash um i love doordash
you know sometimes you don't have time
to
cook
you know sometimes this cooking's not in
your your thing you know what i mean and
so you need some food and maybe you
don't want to go to your favorite
restaurant or maybe you don't and this
is a great way to support your favorite
local restaurants is to use an app like
doordash
um
it's so easy and convenient now that
it's like i don't even think about it
you know they they leave the stuff at
your door if you're worried about covid
you know you know the app is so detailed
about like what you want on your food
take things off put things on it's so
easy you know what i mean
you can even get groceries now or just a
backup meal from your favorite local
restaurant and it's all delivered by
doordash it's time to get back out there
but if you're not quite ready for a full
bone adventure there's still ways to
explore the world from the comfort of
your home with doordash you don't need
to travel far to experience something
new
you know what the past year has taught
us is enjoy every moment savor savor
every moment and savor it with some
savory food right
you don't want to spend time prepping
and cooking
you know you don't have to do it all the
time but there are days where you're
just like you know what i want this fast
i want it now
um
and like i say doordash is totally the
way to go so for a limited time our
listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on the first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code griffin
that's 25 off up to 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code griffin
don't forget that's code griffin for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change turn terms apply
all right let's go to our other sponsor
guys we got two ads today and this is
one of my favorite sponsors it's better
help you know better help we're still
living in crazy times man i'm dealing
with stuff all the time you know and so
check-in would better help it's a great
way to like just
talking about stuff is so important man
i'm in therapy right now
with some family stuff and it just it
unlocks things that i didn't even
realize
was an issue
boundaries and uh abandonment and and
these kinds of things that you don't
even realize but
with a licensed professional that
recognizes patterns from the things that
you say and do they will help you
organize your thoughts and you'll solve
your problems but
when you can understand your problems
you can combat them better
i mean we're all dealing with stuff man
depression stress anxiety relationships
it's not sleeping trauma and this is
convenient it's affordable
and you know
i i highly recommend it it's totally
worth it man it's totally worth it so
guys
better help all right
go out there and start living a happier
better life today all right join over
one million people who have taken charge
of their mental health that's better
help h e l p
dot com slash griffin better help for a
10 off your first month i want you to
start living a happier life and
listeners will get 10 percent off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
griffin
all right guys um
let's see
so somebody asked a question i thought
it's kind of interesting eric how do you
feel about rogan segura
[ __ ] on the comedy store lineups all
the time now are you still doing spots
there yes i am still doing spots there
and so is tom segura when he comes into
town he does spots there so when he's on
the lineup i'm sure he doesn't think
it's shitty uh when i'm on a lineup i
don't think it's shitty but you know is
it is the is the show like
as powerful and strong as it was before
when you had all these dignitaries of
comedy coming there um no because people
are out of town and also not every comic
is vaccinated so they're not letting
every comic perform there but it is what
it is you know you know what i mean i
don't take it personal
listen i'm funny as hell when i'm on the
lineup i know i make the lineup better
so they ain't talking about they just
you know
they they live in austin now and they
collectively want to
they're collectively saying like oh as a
whole we don't like these lineups
anymore that's fine i don't take it
personal because i know when i'm on a
lineup
i'm i'm tearing it up people are having
a good time when i'm on the lineup so i
don't take offense to it so i get i get
what they're uh talking about you know
it it it means nothing to me you know
they'll be back ain't nothing happening
in austin
you know what i'm saying the comedy
scene is not moving to austin sorry
good try
good try though but go get your no no
state tax and you know i'm sure
i'm sure the
huge wealth that rogan has in
la
it's even more in austin all the money
he's saving on taxes and all that stuff
but the comedy universe the mecca of
comedy look at me will never ever be in
austin
okay
so
i don't care you know what i mean
again i don't take offense both guys i
still consider friends i get why they
i remember
uh rogan saying to me he didn't like
uh
he was he he trashes lineups all the
time man don't this ain't a new thing
like a right to my face like i'm going
to the laugh factory and he's like oh
those
lineups are dog [ __ ] i'm like yeah i'm
on the lineup
you know it's like
that's what comics do man we talk [ __ ]
so it is what it is
so i don't i don't i don't don't i don't
really take offense to it and and if you
go to the comedy store
uh
if you go to the comedy store you're
going to have a good time
so
you know what i mean so don't don't
worry about you you'll see because bill
burr still goes there you know we still
got bill burr on the line up we still
got like there's a lot of really funny
people they go bobby lee's there andrew
santino's at the comedy store i'm at the
comedy store there's a lot of funny
people at the connor store that rogan
himself thinks is funny you know so you
know what i mean it is what it is you
know we people like to talk [ __ ] that's
just what the nature of what comedians
do
you know what i mean okay now guys
i this spoiler alert at this point right
now huge spoiler alert but i want to
tell you guys right now even with this
spoiler alert okay even with this
spoiler alert i still think you should
go watch this movie even with what i'm
about to do right now still go watch
this movie
the movie's called
titan i don't even know if i'm saying it
right titan
titan you know there's the girl can you
see her
titan
um i don't know how to say the name but
it's a it's a french movie
um let's go to the imdb real quick let's
go to the imdb
yeah it stars
um
let's see
like these are the director
director julia
daca something you know french or
something i don't know
it
oh my god the act the actress agatha
rosella rosselli she's the star
uh it's it's got a lot of like
interesting people in the movie but this
guys let me tell you something right now
this is
without a doubt
the weirdest movie i've ever seen
in my life
okay so i said we gotta talk about this
movie it's like a french movie it was in
like the cans festival it won a bunch of
awards because it is artsy fartsy as
hell
it is what it is exactly
[Laughter]
fly guys stop talking smack in the chat
it is titan
who knows how to say it
you know what i mean anybody could
somebody phonetically spell it in the uh
in the chat
this is the craziest movie listen to me
people
it's the craziest movie i've ever oh it
means titanium okay got it that makes
sense
okay
movie opens up y'all we're gonna go play
by play for the movie this is the
spoiler alert part right here movie
opens up
a dad and a daughter driving in the car
the daughter's in the back seat behind
the dad she's acting up she's being a
little brat she kicking the back of the
seat okay the dad is like stop it stop
it and you have to read this movie too
by the way it's not on netflix i
actually bought it on amazon i rented it
on amazon bobby lee told me to watch
this movie and him and i got similar
taste and when he says something is
weird i'm like i gotta go watch this
movie okay
teton that's how you say it it's
pronounced titan okay teton
is that right titan titan i don't know
anyway so the little girl's in the back
and she kicking the seat acting up so he
turns around eventually like stop it
right but when he turns around to stop
her cause she unbuckles her seatbelt
they get into a tragic car accident
cut to
this picture right here the little girl
see the little girl she's like in a head
gear because she just had
she just had to get surgery
so she's in like some gear and
obviously you know she was badly injured
in this
car accident
so it's probably a time jump of like
the surgery that they did and they put a
titanium plate
in her head
so she's got this bruise on the side of
her her head where this titanium plate
is
so now she's getting out of the hospital
she's a little girl and she's got her
like little girl jump in swagger and she
goes over to a car
all right
as they they're they we're getting at
the hospital she goes over to her car
and she hugs the car okay
she hugs the car and she kisses the
window of the car
you go okay
you don't know how weird this is
yet
cut to now time jump she's a in a woman
in her 20s
and she's now a model
okay she a model for cars and she's at
this club that there's cars and she's
one of these like beautiful models that
like dances on cars so she's doing like
a striptease dance on cars and she's
like doing that whole thing and it's all
sexy the movie's very sexy it's a lot of
nudity uh the music's great and it's you
know it's gritty
and it's you know like i say it's very
artsy fartsy so she's obviously got like
she got a chip on her shoulder all the
time you can see she's got an attitude
problem so
she finishes her dance and like you know
there's she's taking a shower you know
what i mean and she's uh she's very
weird how she's looking at everybody and
it's all the nudity and then like you
know she's leaving the place and you
know guys are asking for her autograph
and she's giving her autographs so now
she's going out she's leaving the
building and guys are still there and
she goes ah [ __ ] off you know she don't
want to take do any more autographs so
now she start walking to her car which i
don't understand is like eight blocks
away
okay that's the only thing i didn't
understand like
wherever this like stadium was that
they're having this party that she
walking a guy starts following her all
right and then you know she knows the
guy's following and she's getting a
little scared so she runs to her car and
then uh the guy is like talking you know
he's saying her name so she gets to her
car she gets in her car the guy comes to
the car you know and he's like hey she
rolls the window down he's like i just
want an autograph you know
and she's like okay you know what i mean
she's like all right get the autograph
and then he's all like i think i'm in
love with you i know it's weird but i'm
in love with you and she's like looking
at him strange and then he reaches in
the car grabs her face and he just
starts kissing her okay
and then she's like sort of fighting and
then she starts kissing him back but
while she's kissing him back she pulls
out she's got her hair in like a thing
and it's it's a spike that she's got her
hair tied up in she pulls the spike out
and she kills him
i mean just murders him dude
puts puts him in the back of the car
drives off
so you like damn
you don't even know what happens like
you're like i don't know how she got rid
of the body i don't know what happens so
i'm like oh [ __ ]
all right cut to now there's some girl
that sort of interested in her i think
it's one of the other models you know
what i mean i saw the movie like a week
ago so like forgive me if i'm not
getting all the details right but i'm
telling you it's a weird ass movie all
right oh wait wait wait wait wait i'm
skipping something very important
she gets home
now she taking the shower because
when she was stabbing the dude he was
like vomiting like whatever on her so
all over her neck is like his like
death vomit
so you know so she's in the shower she's
like oh my god get this all off of me
she don't kill the dude and she don't
even know what's up why she kills this
she killed the guy i mean he was like
forcing himself on her but even still
like you like killed a [ __ ] all
right anyway
then
the door rattles the front door like
starts to go google
the whole room starts to shake you know
and she butt ass naked right
and then she she stalks over to the door
so at first you think is the guy not
dead and it's him
and then she peeks out the door and
there's a car outside her door
like a car like an old old-ass sort of
cadillac type car
and the headlights are on and the
headlights you know they're blinking the
car is shaking and she's looking at the
car then she walks outside butt ass
naked over to the car and the cars car's
making whatever noise
cut to
she inside the car
having sex
with the car
take take that in
y'all take a moment and take that in she
having sex with the car y'all
she having sex with the car she she got
the seat belts wrapped around both arms
and she in the car and she's like oh
you know what i mean and then the car is
jumping up and down the car is doing
like this like one of those like
you know low rider cars in east l.a and
she's just boom and the music is going
and the the headlights are blinking and
she you can like you're looking at this
and you're like
she [ __ ] the car
like
what
she having sex with the car
so now
you don't know what kind of movie you're
watching at this point all right
okay so it's like is this some magic
stuff is this some weird like christine
some stephen king type stuff so all
right
cut to now
she had sex with this car so now she off
doing her life so anyway one of the
other models who
they were in the shower together earlier
they were in the shower together the
girl got
a nipple
she got nipple um earrings nipple rings
and then the other girl they're looking
at each other and yes
it's some like flirty lesbianics going
on and the girl drops her soap and she
leans down and her hair gets caught on
the girl's nipple so now she's trying to
take her hair out the nipple and it's
all like oh my god you know then she
like rips it off it's like
weird it's sexy but sort of weird you
know what i mean
and then
so now okay so after the the car sex
she's with this girl
at her place
so she at the girl's place you know or
they're out at them like they're out
someplace and she's like have you ever
been with a um a girl before because the
girl the main girl is like sucking on
the girl's nipples with the nipple thing
on you know what i mean and she's like
biting it and she's pulling it and then
the girl's getting uncomfortable the the
other girl would you know she's like
okay i don't know do you know what
you're doing
like it was so like she very much was
like have you ever been with a woman
before because i don't know if this is
like do you like this type of thing her
whole vibe was like yo uh you you
messing with my nipple girl this is too
much and then she's like pulling the the
nipple ring with her teeth and so the
nipple is stretching and then like she
does something and the girl
goes stop it you know what i mean and so
the girl jumps up and the other girl is
like looking at her weird and then
you know but then
so then like this main girl like what's
her name in the movie so we can start
calling her her name in the movie uh
like what what does she play elec alexia
her name's alexia so alexia
she's starting to have stomach pains
like something's going on with her
stomach
all right and she her stomach's starting
to grow
like
y'all the car got her pregnant
car got her pregnant y'all so she
pregnant with a car baby okay
y'all hear what i'm saying
she pregnant with a car baby i already
said the spoiler alert so sorry if
you're just coming in you better turn it
off but i still don't you still should
watch this movie even though i'm
spoiling it all right so now she having
a car baby so now she knows something's
up
and like the other girl is like weirded
out and then she you know she runs over
to her and hugs her she's like oh my god
and then okay so now cut today back at
the girl's apartment
and they're like kissing and they're
like whatever
and then the girl
pulls the spike out
and kills this girl she kills her
i don't know why she kills her
i didn't understand why she kills her
so she kills the girl right
and it's a big battle of killing but
here's the issue
this chick got
four roommates
[Laughter]
so [ __ ] so now
another chick comes out and she's like
oh [ __ ] i gotta kill this [ __ ] too so
now there's a big struggle where she she
got to kill this [ __ ] it's a big fight
on the stairs boom boom boom oh my god
ah you know
she gotta kill her
and then as she kills her she thinks
she's done
a big ass naked black dude comes out the
room
but he's like
a big black dude but he's soft you know
and he's covered he's holding his dick
you know like covering himself up like
um
you know he's asking some weird question
and she's looking at him like
how many of y'all here
so now she got to go up to the black
dude all sensual and she's like she hugs
him and then she kills him
you know and then there's another one
so she got now she massacres all these
roommates
so now
now what's up
they all did so now she in trouble cause
now it's in the news there's a massacre
you know there's a serial killer on the
loose people are dying right so now what
does she do all right
in the movie there's a story on the news
of
a kid who's been missing
so he was he's been missing since he was
like 10 years old and they're all like
have you seen this kid
this chick decides
she's gonna assume
that kid's life
she's gonna pretend she's a dude
and she's the long lost
kid
so the kid looks a certain way
so she
decides that she needs to break her nose
to look like this kid
and this scene
is so graphic
and like i was like looking at it like
oh [ __ ] don't do that what you doing
like she's punching herself in the nose
dude
and it's such an intense scene because
she works herself up and then she like
punches herself and she keeps punching
herself in the nose and you're like
[ __ ] stop and then she looks and she
goes this ain't gonna be it and then
she's in the bathroom right so she's
holding the sink and then she looks at
the edge of the sink like you know what
i gotta break my nose on this sink so
then she like
she like
you know works herself up to like slam
her nose on the sink and it's such an
like the scene is so like it's you're
like no
so she does that all right so now she
shows up at this this family's house
this dude now he's like the chief of the
fire department
he works in fire rescue
at this fireplace with a bunch of dudes
okay so she shows up like hey i'm your
long-lost son the cops she goes to the
police whatever and then like you know
so he picks her up it's a whole thing
they're not sure you know what i mean
because you're not sure
uh
you know and she like cut her hair you
know what i mean to look like a boy and
then remember she also pregnant with a
car baby so the belly's growing and she
got titties so she like keeps wrapping
herself with like uh a medical
uh gauze and really tight where she's
cutting herself so she has to wrap
herself so she can hide the baby and
hide the titties
the dad now this this
police guy this fire chief guy is a
weirdo
he's taking steroids like apparently it
feels like he's about to lose his job or
he can't do the job anymore so he's
taking steroids so he's always butt ass
naked in the in in the bathroom shooting
his booty with steroids and he's weird
he i mean he's weird obviously the loss
of his son has affected him so he's
really enamored by this kid this person
that is now he thinks his son but he
acted weird you know what i mean like
he's being creepy like the way he's
hugging that the boy that he thinks is a
boy but it's this girl you know it's
just like you go are you trying to [ __ ]
your son you know what i mean like it's
like that all right
so
alexia is acting weird so now the the
kid's name is uh adrian
you know it's the boys i think it was
adrian yeah yeah even if it wasn't you
get what i'm saying so he's got this
boy's name now and you know the dad is
like you know
you know i'ma take care of you you're my
son now don't worry but alexia adrian is
all like okay i'm just trying to get
away from because i murdered a bunch of
people so but people are kind of find it
strange like the other guys at the at
the uh firehouse
which is very homoerotic too by the way
this firehouse is
like
like like a gay club on west hollywood
the way people are like interacting and
acting with each other this is some
weird ass [ __ ] man so
now
the father the the the father is like
trying to you know
because
alexia's acting like hey i don't want to
talk because you know i have a woman's
voice and you know what i'm saying like
she's trying to like and so the the fire
the fire guy brings his son along
to join the fire department you know so
she's going on fire trips and
rescue missions but people are starting
to be like
you you seem weird you know like you
seem weird and so like a lot of weird
stuff happens between them you know
and then like the belly keeps getting
bigger and then like she keeps
scratching her belly scratch scratch
catch scratching her belly and then as
she scratches her belly to the point
where the skin breaks and there's like
metal
like her womb is metal and you could see
it through the skin
and you're just like she having a car
baby like what is happening
and then acting all weird and strange
man like the dad is like like the way
the dad is hugging okay so then the mom
shows up okay the mom shows up
and the mom know this ain't her son okay
the mom like this ain't my son she don't
say that but her whole demeanor is like
because she knows her ex-husband because
they've broken up because he went crazy
you know that's what happens a lot in
these situations you know in real life
you know you a kid vanishes or something
happens and the
couple can't stay together because of
guilt or whatever so they're expressing
that so they are broken up so now the
mom knows it's saying her kid you know
and then like all right the the girls in
the room
she takes the gauze off and her titties
are all and her body is all bruised up
and her she's scratching herself and the
titanium is showing you know what i mean
and then like
the mom busts in on her and she sees the
titties and everything but she already
knew
she already knew and she was like oh you
poor thing and then she tells her i
don't know what you're doing but make
sure you take care of you know her
ex-husband
take care of him you know because she
know
this guy needs this you know what i'm
saying
it's so weird
all right
then
the dad sort of
you realize the dad knows this ain't his
son
but he needs it
and he's like he says i don't really
care who you are
you're my son
you know
and like
like
the kid is naked the girl the girl is
naked but she has a towel
and he's like i don't he's holding i
don't care who you are you know and then
the towel falls and he sees the titties
[Laughter]
right
and he don't do nothing
he just grabs the towel puts it back
over and is like you know but i get the
feeling that he obviously was attracted
to
this person you know what i'm saying
because he was acting so weird all right
now cut back to the firehouse there's a
rave going on at the firehouse and this
is what i'm saying how homoerotic it was
all these fire dudes in great shape oh
wait wait let me go back
one of the dudes who was like second in
command with the fire guy he knew
something was up with this person like
he knew also it was a girl so they go on
like a fire
they go on like a huge fire thing and
the fire chief guy the dad
he basically kills this kid because he
knows
he basically allows this kid to die
it was crazy to protect this secret you
know
so then cut to now they're celebrating
this kid this death they're having this
sort of homo rave homoerotic rave where
they're dancing with each other and
whatnot and then like the alexia adrian
is dancing they do a slam dancing and
and then they they they
they pick him up right pick him her up
and like take her and she's on top of
the fire truck and everybody's like hey
adrian adrian and then
she starts dancing
all sexy
like a girl
and then all these dudes with their
shirts off music playing drinking beer
with each other like the scene was like
i said homoerotic is the best way i can
describe it
they looking up at like what you doing
dude
you know they're like like they got
looks like some of them are like okay
and others are like what's happening
right now and i thought that was strange
like you like you acting like this is
out of bounds when all y'all dancing
with each other and acting weird anyway
so then the dad comes
sees you know what i mean
and now
you know they're seen on the news
because what had happened was that one
kid saw
that they have a description of the
killer and it looks just like the guy
but it's a girl so he even says to when
they were out at that fire stop where
they were out this fire big fire in the
woods where the guy had killed him he's
saying like
he says
how do you know her you know like he he
knows it's the girl
so this guy the father that's when the
father decides to kill the guy you know
what i mean
so now the girl's belly is like
protruding and
a situation is happening she's at the
firehouse like she's about to have this
baby oh and
motor oil is coming out of her titties
okay motor oil
you hear what i said motor oil coming
out to titties motor oil coming out her
vagina like she just covered like motor
oils coming out of all her orifices
she's vomiting motor oil because she
having a car baby
then
you know once he realizes
it's like they admit to each other that
it's a girl the father and her they now
they haven't sort of like not romantic
but you feel like oh are they gonna
smash you know what i mean
and then she's like going into labor
you know and it's a weird ass labor the
dad's there
you know trying to help her
and then a little car baby comes out
okay so she has a car baby but the baby
looks like a regular baby but the spine
has like metal
like there's metal on the spine
and the movie ends with the dad holding
this baby which is now going to probably
replace the adrian so who knows what
this dad is going to do with this baby
guys
i don't know what else to say
but
this was
without a doubt
the most bizarre strangest movie
you know what i'm saying this was
the most
strangest movie i have ever seen in my
entire life
all right y'all
um
i don't know what to say another weird
episode of riffing with griffin you know
we do it we do it different all the time
make sure you check me out on twitch
uh
daily i'ma go on twitch in probably 30
minutes after this
um
you know check out this movie
wherever you can like rent it or
whatever it's totally bizarre movie i
know i completely spoiled the whole
movie but it actually gonna help you
when you watch to be like what
so
check that out
um thanks for watching griffin with
griffin
shout out to doordash and uh better help
shout out to all you guys in the chat
for being here appreciate you
uh my schedule is up you know i'm gonna
be at the la jolla comedy store this
coming weekend and i'm gonna be at the
arizona and stand up live in arizona in
phoenix next weekend
so you know if you're in those areas
come and check me out
shout out to rachel and i hate my
boyfriend's couch and this great art
that was uh
uh submitted by
rgb underscore arts on
instagram
and you know what i appreciate you guys
being here every single week and i will
see you
next
week
peace
[Music]